sie sind überzeugt wissenschafts
feindlich und sie werden immer mehr
impfgegner aber was sind ihre argumente
und wieso finde ich so viele von ihnen
auf heilpraktiker kongress
[Musik]
was sagen sie zur impfpflicht finde ich
nicht in ordnung weil es
körperverletzung ist also sie haben
keine kinder aber würden sie auch nicht
impfen ja eher tendenz zum nicht impfen
ja eher schauen eben dass das milieu
stimmt dem kind dann würde ich als
befürworterin jetzt sagen gut dass sie
gar nicht haben
wir machen viele fehler die einfach
krank machen sind durch sümpfe es stimmt
die krankheiten und das ist ja ein
bisschen so als würde ich die post nur
noch per brieftaube verschicken weil ich
mal von der bekannten gehört habe dass
die per dhl was geschickt hat das nicht
angekommen ist ganz allein mehr als 95
prozent der leute geimpft sind dann
herrscht der herdenimmunität denn mehr
als 95 prozent geimpft werden
nein es ist ein ganz andere fahrer das
system ist die frage ja das
gesundheitssystem es fängt mit ernährung
an mit gedanken emotionen partnerschaft
heilung und es geht darum die heilkraft
des sonnenlichts die wir zu den talenten
der pflanzen noch mit in unserem
mittelchen haben
wie macht man sonnenlicht in eine
flasche benzin die sonne
hier haben wir ja diese dieses was die
erklärung destination und verarschung
paar schauer und von der alchemie
gleiche mischung des unten oder der
pflanze wie es damit typische kundschaft
wir sind natürlich sehr aufgeschlossen
das ist natürlich alles verkaufen dann
nehme ich das einfach und dann reicht
das nicht aus er muss da nicht noch
jemand sagen was ihm vorher gesagt dass
sie eine information zur
problembewältigung auf so ein stein
lagen in mein problem wäre jetzt diese
vehementen gegner das ist ein wirkliches
problem dass wir nicht können sie mich
davon heilen ja das kann ich wir machen
das so dass sie nicht mehr so extrem mit
den impfgegner oder in resonanz gehen
man sollte also nicht versuchen dass der
partner die socken aufräumt oder das ist
manipulation sondern nur wenn er kommt
und ein problem hat dann können wir das
für ein
muss ich einfach den teil des gehirns
rausschneiden der sich daran stört dass
da sorgten oben liegen zum beispiel ja
sie haben selber eine tochter die nicht
geimpft wurde
sein 20 und würde die oft krank nein nie
das ist aber ja vielleicht weil alle
anderen geimpft sind
das kann ich nicht beurteilen so das ist
ja wie wenn dann wenn alle anderen in
der sauna flipflops an haben und sie
gehen basis rein dann kriegen sie auch
ganz ins bild im internet
das ist für mich persönlich entscheiden
kommt und für mich genau und der rest
soll schauen ja sie sind positiv drauf
wenn sie das trinkwasser haben nein es
ist nicht halluzinogen und kirche ist
fantastisch als eine botschaft an den
gesundheitsminister jens spahn es wäre
auch mal schön wenn man nach einer
kinder höre dass die haltbarkeit
strenge und harte ausbildung haben bevor
sie auf die menschheit losgelassen
werden
ich hab was probiert an dem stand und zu
viel gewesen
kann das sein ja das problem ist dass
jeder dass die erfahrung dass sein
körper sammeln muss
impfgegner gehen gar nicht und ich gehe
jetzt nach hause
also ich versuche es zumindest guten tag
könnte ich sie für ein abo des heute
show you tube kanal als begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort